the authorities on the Indonesian island
of java so at least 56 people have died
and 700 have been injured in an
earthquake Sky correspondent shiman
Freeman Powell joins us live now from
The Newsroom as shiman what does the
latest we know about this well we know
that the earthquake with a magnitude of
around 5.6 was strong enough to be able
to collapse walls and topple buildings
and we've heard from the national
disaster mitigation agency that this is
likely the lead cause of deaths and
injuries and as you've just said we know
that at least 56 people have died as a
result of the earthquake and that
hundreds more have been injured we've
seen footage of tiles and concrete
falling down and I believe we're now
looking at images of what once used to
be a super market which is now being
turned into Rubble we've seen similar
images as well in hospitals with people
running out of buildings trying to find
Safe Haven now we also know that their
children own region has been one of the
hardest hit regions and the emergency
workers have been trying to treat the
injured on stretches outside of
hospitals and in car Parks as well now
this is the images of the hospital that
has been affected we can see cracks in
the walls and people desperately trying
to escape the hospital as well now we
have heard from the national disaster
agency who said that people are likely
still trapped under buildings that have
turned into Rubble they say that around
1 700 houses have been damaged and it's
caused nearly 4 000 people to be
displaced in their children region so
emergency workers and rescue teams will
now be trying to reach those people that
attract under those buildings as well as
going to the more isolated areas and
Villages trying to assess the damage
there to and officials will be working
hard not only to identify those that
have died but to also so identify the
number of casualties as that number is
likely to rise